this gentleman um caught no fewer than
three touchdown passes
three touchdown passes in the first half
for the
3-0 seattle seahawks and he is the third
player
to be awarded the snickers uh hungriest
player of the week
chain um and he's the first player to be
awarded this knickers chain for the
second year in a row how about that
breaking new ground
back here on the rich eisen show is
tyler lockett of the seattle seahawks
how are you tyler
doing pretty good how's everybody doing
today we are doing better for talking to
you
you are a dynamite football player that
seems to be improving with each passing
game just like your quarterback and team
but before i get to all of that i do
want to put right in front of you your
thoughts upon hearing
uh your colleagues in tennessee three of
them on the football field
five of them in the personnel department
that tested positive for coronavirus
what goes through your head when you do
that when you hear that
tyler uh i mean it's very unfortunate
you know we've been in a time that
nobody really thought would ever happen
has been a pandemic that
slowed a lot of things down and this was
just the concern that a lot of people
had when they were trying to figure out
whether they wanted to play or not
but we trust that the nfl nflpa
did exactly what needed to be done
within the protocols that allowed us to
come up here
that allowed us to feel safer to be able
to come out here and play
and and to play exactly what we're doing
this for
so we trust that the protocol is going
to be able to
to help out but we also just going to
keep in prayers everybody that ended up
testing positive and just praying that
no harm is going to be done but that
everybody will just continually be safe
well and again um we just never know
how you can contract this virus i mean
we can guess and obviously you know with
families
um and that everyone is going home to
you you never know
uh but that said what is the
conversation that you've had and we know
there was an incident in the preseason
where
a teammate of yours got cut um
for seemingly playing a little bit fast
and loose with everything
what's the conversation you've had
internally there about staying safe
and going home and staying home and
being vigilant about it
tyler well i mean you know
uh that was like a false
positive and for us but i think the
biggest thing is just
we all have to do our part in order to
be able to stay safe so
if we do have family come out here if we
do have friends come out here like
you know we have it set up to where we
can try to get our families tested and
stuff like that
commit to be able to make sure that
we're keeping everybody safe
i think that's the biggest thing that
you could do everybody just has to be
able to do their part
that still doesn't mean that you can't
contract the virus but it just puts us
in a better
situation to not be able to get it and
so i think
like you said you can think about how do
you contract it how can you not
all those different types of things but
i think it just creates so much anxiety
it's almost just you just gotta be able
to just just
you know um figure out what happens if
you end up getting it but you can't live
and feel your whole life but you got to
do what you can to protect yourself at
the same time
tyler lockett here on the rich
eisenhower before we do get to the
football
i do want to stay on the life issues
with you because you've got a lot more
on the figurative ball than just
football
last time you came on i think you came
on to talk about some of your poetry
and you've written some poems i know
that the nfl network we we aired a piece
of your poem being read by many of your
colleagues across
the nfl on the issues of social justice
and i'd love to give you the floor
on that tyler and how everything is
going about you getting your
message and the conversation out in the
conversation
continuing well yeah well i'm thankful
that the nfl gave me an opportunity
they came to me with an amazing idea and
asked if
i'd be willing to write a piece and you
know i took the opportunity i
thought it was a really great piece i
got a lot of great feedback from a lot
of people especially from back home or
people that talk to my family about it
and just thankful that a lot of
people in the league came across to want
to be a part of the video and just the
way that it was displayed the way that
it went i thought it was really amazing
i thought that it got our point across
of everything that it was
during that video that we wanted to
present to each and every person
just with everything that's going on i
think we all just have to figure out our
role
what it is that we feel um our part is
and this to be able to make a difference
because not everybody's going to have
the same part
we all play different parts in the body
and every part is
going to be significant to being able to
bring and promote change
and so i think that for me i'm trying to
find my part
and i'm continuing to find a way to be
able to present the message that i want
to be able to display
and to be able to not only bridge the
gap but to eliminate that gap to where
we can all be seen as one
yeah reality versus perception is the
poem that you penned and everyone should
go to nfl.com to see the reading of it
included aaron
donald saquon adrian peterson and more
really was uh
very moving and just beautiful tyler it
really was and i'm glad to hear that you
got the reaction
that you got what about next steps
before again we get to the football and
and everything else what about next
steps here
for you uh well i mean there's a lot of
different steps that you could take but
like i said a lot of people are just
coming up with a lot of different ways
and a lot of people are coming up with
documentaries and just different things
like that to be able to get the point
across
i think for me it's being able to use
you know my performance and arts to be
able to get it across in different ways
whether it's poetry whether it's me
standing up being able to speak
whether it's being able to like i said
bridge the gap
i think it's just it it's not just one
step that's going to make everything
right it's going to be multiple steps
that's going to be taken but everybody
just has to continue
to move in the same direction so for me
even
um you know if i have people that are
caucasian then i hang out around or
that i know like if they come to me and
they ask questions and they want to know
like i'm able to present it to them
but i try to talk to people who want to
learn who want to know more who want to
understand rather than people who just
don't want to talk about
it at all or who's just blind to the
fact of what's actually going on
so i try to do the best that i can to
talk to people and to give them
information and knowledge
to tell them to watch certain tv show or
certain movies
such as like detroit or even just mercy
or the 13th documentary on netflix like
try to just get them to see a lot of
this stuff so they can understand
what it's like that we go through if
they've never even tried to pay
attention to it
tyler lockett here on the rich eisen
show let us move
to your football team and the offense
that appears so explosive
the conversation has been about the
hashtag let russ cook that
that the offense is different is it
different this year
tyler you doing anything differently uh
i mean i think we're just taking more
chances
than we usually have done i think that
the best part about us right now is that
we're playing aggressive
and we're not allowing the defense to
determine what we do as an offense where
we're going to be the one to push the
buttons on the defense
and i think that's one of the best
things about what we're doing this year
i think we got a lot of great players on
our team that's able to make plays and
so
doesn't matter what teams do what
against us we have
a lot of great players in different
positions that can be able to make
highlights tight plays and so for us
just being able to have the opportunity
to go out there and play when we see
what teams are trying to do who they're
trying to take away we're able to
exploit match-ups and exploit coverages
that help benefit us so uh normally i
know you don't
want to talk about anything that goes on
internally but uh
have you reviewed film of dk metcalf's
first would-be touchdown and if so how
much crap
has he received or how much do you think
he will receive if you have yet to go
over that film session
tyler lockett no we already went over
the film session and stuff
but uh it was just you know a casual
conversation to just
you know make sure you just play all the
way through
you know wait until the whistle is
blowing or waiting so you know you're in
the end zone
but you know ultimately like we trust dk
and we weren't worried about that play
at all
a lot of people might really highlight
that play and
make it look more significant than it
really was but
i mean we wouldn't have won the game had
russ not throwing him the ball and he
scored that last
touchdown so it ended up working out and
so it's more so of a learning experience
rather than a history lesson and so i
think for us
you know we're grateful that we were
able to get the win and we know that
it's a learning experience not only for
him but for all of us
you can either learn by experiencing it
or you can learn by going through it
and so for a lot of us in the room a lot
of us have as
a unit we just learned about it as we
went through it together but
the thing about us is we pick each other
up and we continue to play
we don't dwell off of one mistake we
don't dwell off of
one bad play we just continue to play
and we continue to fight and that's what
makes
us as a team so special well in terms of
what's special to
tyler you know um a third round draft
choice
where you had to really prove yourself
and then make the most of your
opportunity is something that would
describe your quarterback
as well as you i'm wondering if you
have any inspiration from what you saw
of russell did with his opportunity and
what you've blossomed into
for him with him what you're
experiencing together
right now tyler
yeah well i think um honestly i think
it's just the power of who you're doing
this for and why you're playing the game
a lot of people have a goal of being
able to get to the nfl and that's what
the goal has always been
ever since they were a little kid but
once they get to the nfl what's the goal
now
you've already accomplished the very
thing that you set out to accomplish as
a kid
but you have to continue to be willing
to set goals for yourself or continue to
be willing to stay true to why you
decided to play this game in the first
place
and i think that's what separates a lot
of guys that stay in the league and a
lot of guys who just end up being in the
league
there's so many distractions that come
with being in the nfl that some people
get swayed by those distractions
and they never reach their full
potential of who they could have became
in the league so i think when you look
at me and rush like
we have our reasons on why we play and
that's what motivates us that's what
inspires us
when we don't feel like practicing or
don't feel like going into a game like
the very foundation the root of why we
do it
always allows us to excel in
in trying to be better every single step
of the way as we play
and really it's just about being given
an opportunity once you're given that
opportunity it's on you
you can't look at it and say well i
gotta play my cards right
i gotta hope this person gets hurt this
person no you just go do what you do
you know if you focus on your gift your
gift will make room for you and that's
just what's been happening
the more you perfect it the more that
you master it
the more doors that'll be open to you
but you got to be faithful over a little
before you could become rule over much
more
i love that answer tyler lockett and i'm
but when i say that i don't mean like
you it's a pat
answer it's beautiful it's amazing it's
inspirational it's awesome
that's i i can't wait to replay that
over and over again for my audience
that's
incredible um you know all that said
though you're
i gave you a choice you only have two
choices this sports talk radio
conversation
your first half three touchdown
performance
what gave you more enjoyment that this
past weekend
that or kansas state coming back and
sticking it to oklahoma
which one gives you more joy tyler
for sure
that gives you more pleasure because i
was i was definitely upset we lost
arkansas
okay and i was i was a little worried i
was like man
you know we might get beat by ou if we
you know we play like that versus
arkansas state but
i've seen one of my teammates um his
name is keenan
he had posted on facebook you know
usually when we go down to ou
we usually beat all you and i and i
remember like yeah when i was there we
beat all you at ou
twice and so i had toast with my
teammates like usually when we play down
there we do beat them
and then they came all the way back in
one so i was definitely excited to see
them
being able to have that victory
especially with all the times and stuff
that's going
on but that was a big confidence boost
just because of what happened last
that week when we lost arkansas state
but it just shows that we're still the
team that we are
and that teams can't sleep on us i guess
not
no doubt that was a hell of a hell of a
win that said your performance did get
you the snickers chain
that's awarded to the player has shown
the most hunger for their big plays and
moments on the field and
uh at your on your twitter handle and on
your social media handles uh
what does a chain look like for those
who might not see it tyler
man i tell you what the change is
definitely amazing
being able to just wear it and even when
you wear it it'll say like hungry at the
bottom
like and the best part about it though
is like ben baller made the change he's
a big-time seahorse fan if a lot of
people don't know
and so just being able for him to award
it to a seahawks player
that's big time and honestly to have the
opportunity to be able to win it twice
to win it last year and to be able to
win it this year and to know that i'm
the first person that did that
like that's a blessing you know that's
truly a blessing for me and i give god
all the glory with that
and i'm just excited to be able to have
the chain and where to chain
i think snickers is doing an amazing job
with with
this whole concept of what it means to
be hungry and
even when you get it that doesn't mean
that you know you're
you're done and that you're satisfied it
just means that the hunger has to
continue
to build it has to continue to grow has
to continue to push you
and so for me i'm just hungry and
honestly like i want more like
this makes you want to be able to do
more and be more and it's not only for
my own success but it's also
to be able to be hungry to serve others
because that's when you become more
successful
tyler lockett at td lock at 12. everyone
should check that out on
on twitter and instagram um comeback win
for your alma mater
three touchdowns in the first half
three-and-oh team
the the chain it's all good in your
world and we appreciate
just being rent payers for this
conversation thank you
thank you so much appreciate that let's
chat soon that's tyler
lockett